I think really the only useful advice I  ever got in terms of you know trying to  figure out your way in to the film  business of film industry is to get  yourself a script and hang on to it  um it's that idea  that's screenplay that that concept you  know whatever that's going to be that's  so important and you have to stick to  your guns you have to find something  that you can do  that maybe other people couldn't do and  even if that seems different or doesn't  fit into people's expectations that's  what's going to distinguish it if you  can do it successfully so I think it's  really about sticking to your guns and  you know doing something you  passionately believe in rather than  trying to appeal to some desire that you  imagine other people have for what they  want to see in a film I think you have  to be true to your own passion and your  own sense of what excites you as a  storyteller